let's talk about what's going on with
the supreme court oh this is fun
yeah so the supreme court has agreed to
hear a case on carrying guns in public
i mean that's the breaking news right so
it's uh they say the justices who have
not issued it
who have not issued a major second
amendment ruling since 2010
will hear a challenge to a new york gun
control law
it's uh they've granted what is it a
writ of don't say sir sir
don't say the long word i don't know how
to say it certainly or certainly
certainly something like that
so so the supreme court said on monday
that it would review a new york law that
imposes strict limits on carrying guns
outside the home
setting the stage for its first major
second amendment case in more than a
decade
the move came in in the wake of a recent
spate of mass shootings
which were followed by calls from biden
and other democrats for stricter
restrictions on firearms it kind of
sounds like they're going in the other
direction though
well let me know for sure there's
there's that dusty old parchment that
nobody wants to read anymore that every
once in a while these guys pull out
you know and they take a look at and
it's actually got some words in it
and keep and bear are co-equal
all right so we've we've pretty much
established you can keep arms
you know they like to argue about which
ones but that's kind of dc versus heller
but it's a pretty broad interpretation
on that
in common use and useful in the militia
that's a lot of guns
now bear arms what does bear arms mean
the fun thing is in
in dc versus heller judge scalia had or
justice scalia had a
blast dogging the other justices who
were trying to present
pretend that bear arms was only for
military use or only meant in the home
well you don't bear an arm in your home
you know
you don't you bear in mind when you take
it into action
that is it is an action verb bearing
arms
how can you secure a free state if you
can't leave your house with your weapon
yeah you know there's a lot of large
swaths of that state that are outside my
house
that actually impact my life and so
right now i have a concealed carry
permit in virginia
i can carry concealed or i can carry
openly because virginia is an open carry
state
but if i go to dc where i actually need
a gun
i can't carry one legally right that's
garbage here's what
here's what's interesting here the hill
says supreme court declines to take up
three gun ownership cases this is from
the 19th now when this
came out people were upset they were
like oh here it is the supreme court's
not going to hear the cases
it could just be that they decided it
would be pointless
to take up these three when they take up
when they can take up this one
yeah and this this one they're taking up
is fairly broad they've got a chance to
decide
what type of restrictions you can place
on open or concealed carry as it applies
to all 50 states
and what they need and what there's a
there's a very outstanding we mentioned
it earlier the firearms policy coalition
put out a great amicus curiae brief
which is probably pretty mispronounced
but it said the idea is that the lower
courts want guidance
they're acting on their own right now
and they're all going in different
directions
some of them are saying you can have no
restrictions some some and some
anything you want so they need guidance
from the supreme court which is why they
took this case
they can give one set of guidance that
says and i think this is why they do
we'll find out
but they can say okay you can uh you ha
you have to issue
a permit if you're going to require a
permit it has to be shall issue
not may issue which is the way they get
around that so shall issue
and you can't put undue burden on the
person applying
in order to make the process so onerous
which they that they do yeah that's what
i mean at dc
dc versus heller was about it's so hard
to get a permit and you couldn't get one
unless you disassembled the gun
huh a gun that's disassembled is really
hard to shoot somebody with
so it's still almost impossible to get a
gun in dc yeah and and this is another
the
chance though to ratchet that up another
notch
you know so scalia went a long way in dc
versus heller i think this is going to
be the next step
i think we've got a solid 5-4 majority i
hope justice thomas writes it
right because he would be a savage on
this and
he's due to do something like that you
know he's been around long enough
he wants a legacy this would be a great
legacy scalia has heller he'd have that
and then write one that says um yeah
actually the words in the constitution
that are in english that are really easy
to understand
they meant what they said holy crap well
will this have any effect on like atf
regulations in
nfa potentially that's interesting i
don't think it needs to
all right because it's not about what
type of guns it's about can you take
any gun right right a 22 pistol up
through
you know a 308 sniper rifle you can you
can either carry them or you can't
and what restrictions can you or can't
you put on
the open or concealed carry of any of
those and then do we get concealed carry
reciprocity
right so that if i have a virginia
license and i have to go into dc
i can carry where i need to it is insane
that you can be a law abiding citizen
driving from one place to another
and that state could still try and
arrest you now there's a federal law
protecting you
if you're tr if you're traveling with
weapons through the states
however they say well you know if you're
if you get off the highway for gas or
something
they can try and get you yeah i know
people who have who have uh suffered
because of that yeah i
i don't recognize the right of any state
to disarm me
so i will admit that i have violated
laws about that
because i i just don't think they have
the right to i would think i think it's
incumbent on the government
to make it legal to exert exercise my
constitutional rights
and i think i would love to think this
is the time it's going to happen
so this the supreme court could put out
a blanket ruling that
what if what if they put out a blanket
ruling saying not outright there
there can be no laws regulating the
right to keep and bear arms you know
therefore
you don't need a permit at all uh no i
think they're gonna if they do a broad
one i think they will recognize certain
classes of restrictions
felons you know crazy people whatever
the the things are
there's a fairly broad set of things 12
year olds
right and all 12 year olds open caring
but whatever it is why not
well because they're 12. and i i don't
believe children are adults
so i'm willing to make a distinction
what was what was the age of adulthood
when the founding fathers were the
second amendment yeah i don't care our
kids have gotten a lot dumber since then
so
so what's what's the argument then in 50
years when they're like you got to be 30
to own a gun
because 26 year olds are just out of
school you know well we changed that
right you can you can change stuff like
that
i think what you want to establish
though is there has to be a rationale
that is
widely agreed on not just a very narrow
niche thing that says well we're kind of
scared of guns so we're going to make it
almost impossible for anybody to carry
guns in our neighborhood
is another interesting thing though i
mean in in many red states they're
passing constitutional carry
i think was it was it iowa or was it
utah was it utah iowa
uh texas now may is on the verge of
passing constitutional carry
so what do i care if new york does i
don't live there i suppose people of the
state of new york
might appreciate having this ruling for
sure and it's a good thing if we get
clarification because
the main point actually i don't think is
a is either pro or anti-2a
the main point is that how can we have
different standards across the board for
what the rules are
some states say this some states say
that some counties say something
different
we need guidance on the supreme court
that explains to us what the rules are
so that there's a there's you know
uniformity i suppose and the other thing
is the second amendment is not a
second tier amendment right now it's
treated differently than the other
amendments in that
they have to provide cause and do other
things you know it's in
it contingent on certain things that
free speech is not you know that the
right to not self-incriminate is not
there are no
contingencies there there should be no
contingencies
other than the legitimate you know
things that we agree
these people should not have guns and
let's let's make that as narrow as
possible i wonder if
we're consistently moving towards more
and more rights of the constitution
interestingly
you know there was the period of war
where we didn't have free speech we had
the office of censorship
and then free speech as we know it i
think didn't take effect until like the
60s
because there was a period where you
couldn't yell fire in a crowded theater
and then that was over
overturned i think something like 40 or
50 years later so
then we actually said okay free speech
means you can actually do these things
i think there's a there's i think it's
earlier than that i'm not sure when
brandenburg v ohio was but it was
it was somebody knows put it in the chat
and then lydia will tell us
but the bottom line is that that is not
contingent
you know and and we moved towards the
idea that the
the common sense english words in the
constitution mean what they say
okay yeah so there was a ruling i think
it's uh
the initial one was was it abrams i
think was it 19 uh no schneck
schenk 1919 was when the justice was
like you can't say fire in a crowded
theater
and then in 1969 they're like actually
you can right you just can't
incite to you know imminent lawlessness
or whatever yeah and it has to be
something that was going to happen
so let's let's have a reasonable
standard like that and that's that's
understood because what one of the
things that scalia did in dc versus
heller
is he codified the individual right he
said here's what this actually means
it should be in common use and it should
be useful for
potential service in the militia all
right that's simple
and that can change over time it was a
musket now it's an ar-15
good let's go with it i i do love just
the
i you know i i don't think uh
conservatives should be all that worried
or actually no maybe they should be
there's pros and cons to having an
argument with someone who has no idea
what they're talking about
you know it's really hard for them to
properly regulate firearms and they
don't know what they are
right so it's like we're gonna ban
ar-15s and you're like all right my aks
are good
you know it's like you know what you're
talking about no so there's a bunch of
different kinds of guns
you don't know what you're talking about
yeah the other problem is that they're
like fully semi-automatic assault rifles
must be banned and you're like i got no
idea what that is
does that come with a chainsaw bayonet
yes the problem then is you get cops who
are like i don't know you're under
arrest
i've i've talked to cops all right
so uh i'm moving out here and i'm you
know there's some areas
because we're really close to the state
border so i'm like i'm going to ask the
different states you know what their
rules are
first thing the gun shop told me was
don't bother they have no idea what
they're talking about
and so sure enough i'm like all right
well let me let me call one of these you
know departments in a nearby you know
across in a different state not one that
i live in and ask them what their rules
are just in case
and he's like you need a permit and i
was like so if i have like a long gun in
my trunk and there's no ammo you need
a permit and i was like okay so like
even long guns like in the trunk
yes and i'm like so handguns permit and
i'm like how do you get a permit for a
long gun no
you get a permit and i'm like okay thank
you have a nice day there's
you don't get a permit that's that's
ridiculous like the cop didn't so
imagine that cop pulls you over
you got a permit for this you know 410
brake action you know
it's like no my smoothbore brown best
that i was bringing
to the reenactment flintlock you need a
permit for this i don't even know how to
get a permit for this
you know it's a flintlock you don't even
you don't need an ffl for this and
they're like you're under arrest
and it's going to happen and that's
that's the problem with cops in these
blue areas
so going back to it someone had to fund
them whatever because then i'll tell you
this personal responsibility
if you want to live there and these
people are saying defund the police and
you won't take responsibility for
defending them
then i'm not going to defend you either
i'll tell you this if you still want to
live there and you won't take
responsibility for
protecting yourself i'm not going to
defend you either and those two things
dovetail perfectly which is why i carry
you know i i'm
relatively certain that there's not a
cop following me everywhere i go
if there is he's really good right and
that's one sneaky guy
but if there isn't i know that i can
take care of myself now i'm not
i'm not usually the prey but it doesn't
matter i carry
so that i could intervene if someone
else is being abused
you know if you don't have a gun i'm 100
less likely to intervene in a bad
situation than i am if i do
because i know i have the trump card
right so i will help people
and that's that's not good for society
maybe you shouldn't though
if people don't take responsibility for
themselves you you run the risk of
facing
liability for intervening thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show
come back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time